good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is master one thing over
to you Tony Robbins most people who
start business very often will start 2 &
3 for more her and the reason they do it
is does the first one isn't succeeding
or they no longer an agent exactly right
and so what happens that person is
they're never going to be successful in
most case unless they get lucky you get
more people bounce across something
that's easier to do but most people are
always looking for that next level what
my view is is it's great to test all
these things but you got to find what is
your flagship but what is it that you're
gonna commit your soul to because if you
don't do that the inevitable channels
are going to come up and you're gonna
then move on to something on your
personal level and so the other thing I
look at is business is about constantly
exploding such massive value doing more
for others anybody else but it's also
simultaneously about your own psychology
it's your ability to go through
thresholds of control it's like I can
remember when I didn't have $50,000 to
keep the doors open on my company I had
12 employees and 11 wanted to quit cuz
they hated the person running the show
and $50,000 to be like 500 million to me
today and I figured out how to get
through that threshold and once I did
like all the problems are related that
were handled I know you've done this as
well and then I you know I have a five
million dollar lawsuit was totally
unfair unjust and I finally had a just
amount of time entertaining I had to
bite the bullet do it five million was
more than I've ever met
let me have a partner who took the
company losing a million dollars a day
and turn into 1.5 billion and positive
EBIT uh I'm not mentioning names my and
he wanted me to join him in business
with some other partners not doing the
multi-level side did the business put in
10 million bucks we all put in ten
millions forty million a day but I
signed joint in several which I didn't
understand in those days what that meant
and two of my partners were supposedly
billionaires and they went broke
we bought some more companies I end up
with a hundred and twenty million
dollars in debt that I was on the hook
or no one else had any money and I'm
giving up to do a seminar want to throw
up there's a new threshold of control so
you know when you ski or snowboard and
you think you're maybe you're just new
at it and you think you're going down a
blue or green it turns out to be a
double block yeah and so you have two
choices one is you start to go down and
you freak out you're gonna die you slam
on the ground try to hang on for dear
life or the other as baby you focus on
where you want to go and gabi the weight
curve you find a way to cut and once you
do it a couple of times you know you
have no more fear of that element not my
biggest one out of that that led me to a
billion I have 31 companies now to give
you an idea seven different industries
its diverse like you know stem cells to
personal reality with the exclusive to
the NBA now virtually out to get an
example and we do I got 1,200 ploys
we're on three continents and we got
five billion dollars in sales
but I did that my first state on one
freakin yeah exactly so masterful at it
so one of the messages that I've
repeated over and over and over again in
this channel because it's so important
is the number one rule about making
money which is if you want to make money
have to provide value so number one rule
about making money the more value you
can provide somebody a client was facing
a problem of frustration the more money
you're gonna be able to make the more
money you're gonna be able to charge if
you want to make money quickly provide
value quickly that's how it works the
challenge is being able to provide the
value because when you first start off
in business you don't know enough to
provide amazing value you can provide
some value you can help people out but
you can't provide enough value to charge
a premium price yet and that comes
through mastery that comes from
understanding the thing that you want to
be amazing that that you want to be
world-class at that you want to be the
Tony Robbins of add what is that thing
and go all-in and focus on it and get
better and get better and get better and
get better you can get better quickly if
you focus on practice on it you can
outpace your competition really quickly
like I did at my agency because I was
making multiple videos a day where they
were making one video a month or one
video a week and having a really hard
time with that like you can get better
really quickly with dedicated focused
effort on it but most people don't do
that too many entrepreneurs are super
scattered
and it's extra hard because maybe you
have a full-time job you haven't quit
yet you got family of other commitments
plus you have a hundred ideas in your
head and so you're starting this and
doing this and starting that and doing
this and then if I look at your
productivity of actually moving forward
on that thing that you have the ability
to be Tony Robbins level at how much
time are you really spending on that one
thing would be like a start and a stop
and a start and a stop and maybe on
Monday and then pull back and they may
begin on Friday and then pull back and
you never put in enough actual work on
that thing to become the Tony Robbins to
become world class at that thing and
that's where you're gonna provide lots
of value and that's where you gonna make
lots of money that's what you need to
really get really good at otherwise
you're gonna constantly play in this
average zone if you look at this channel
you look at the top ten series that you
guys love and it's what you know we're
known for there's lots of people who are
trying to copy that this lots of people
trying to make their own top tens it's
great we do one five days a week right
like we're working on a new top ten five
days a week we've been doing it for I
don't know how long I don't know any top
tens we have there's a lot if you want
to come into this market right if you
want to now compete a lot of people did
was they make like one a month to a
month and they're trying to make it and
they're trying to do better but it's
like the start and stop and start and
stop you're never gonna win by making
that level of quantity because the
quantity leads to the quality the more
you do the better it's gonna get and the
more you'll find your own flavor and
style you'll you'll find a way to make
your own top ten that's different than
mine on its own path right like you
can't just be a carbon copy of somebody
else you can start by copying but then
you need to find your own twists and
maneuvers and make it better but it's
not gonna happen doing it once or twice
a month when people in your industry are
doing it every day right you need to get
better you need to get mastery and so
one of the hardest things for a lot of
entrepreneurs to do is to focus because
it's so exciting and that's so fun to
work on lots of different ideas right if
you're an ideas person right it's just
oh this is great and this is great know
this and McDonald's could really use
this and staples could use this and like
I can walk into any business and think
of ways that they could make things
better and that's exciting and it's a
great brain exercise but you don't want
get great at anything until you start
executing you start doing and so being
able to take those ideas and then focus
to say of all these things like this is
what I want to get really great at this
is a skill that I want to learn to be
one of the best in the world that sort
can provide any same value to my
customers to my market outpace my
competition make a ton of money in the
process have a huge impact on the world
this is what I want to do it's the
people who are masters at their skill
set who end up making the big impact
making the big dollars making the big
changes and the people who are average
or just above average constantly live a
small life and so you have to make a
choice what do you want to do do you
want to start and stop and start and
stop and never get good at anything and
bounce them one idea to the other and
even if you have one great idea to never
really fully commit to it and and then
you you know ten years blow by and
nothing major has happened because
you've never actually committed serious
time to doing it or you want to say no
this is important my time is important
this project is important the impact
that this is gonna have is important the
result that is going to create for
myself for my family for my community
for the people around me is important
and I'm going to dedicate myself to
becoming a master at it stop trying to
be okay at a thousand things and master
the one thing that you could be Tony
Robbins level act do that you start
having tremendous success so the
question today today is what do you want
to master what is the big thing that you
want to master it's your big goal you
want to be one of the best in the world
at this thing what is it I'm curious
leave it down in the comments below I
want to see your answers I also want to
give a quick shout out to Tim Hogan from
joven farms Tim thank you so much for
picking up a cup in my book your one
word it really means a lot to remain and
I hope you enjoyed the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you guys again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
vinspresso
more Express Oh give me go
came to the the mindset when I was in
film school marked that I did not want
to be a one-and-done I not want to be a
flash in the pan
I wanted to be here for the long haul
I wouldn't incur a South the great
affair career saw what I'm doing is
doing press was one of his last times
Ron his journals asked him you wanted a
greatest master filmmakers of all time
what else you still have to learn and
Kurosawa said I still have a universe to
learn so I was in film school you know
and that blew my mind the baddest
[ __ ] ever right he's 85 eighth
grade at four he says he saucy saucy
University learn as far as storytelling
yeah that really hit me like you know
you you really got a like the Jazz term
you got you got to stay in the woodshed
you got a [ __ ] you know and constantly
be honest perfecting your crap and never
get to the point that you you trick
yourself of thinking that you know it
all yeah it's a life long journey you
know what distorts to tell stories how
to craft them just be a good
storytelling and you do that by having a
body of work so it's always been on the
body of work yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
I did the same thing I locked myself in
my room like all those college that was
it I just worked my ass off in my room
and cancer right Kent's recording and I
wasn't great going into college but all
that time I got out I'm trying to like
learn a little bit of the cracks
[Music]
by the time I got out of college I wear
this look on
outliers by Malcolm Gladwell nobody's
read this book exam it is very right and
Malcolm Gladwell fix this place says
it's not about what the blanket is not
about the talent dish of water with it's
about the hours that she's put into that
summer and he says that a rat if you
want to be a master whatever it is that
you love to do if you want to develop
that craft is its potential what you
have to do is work you have to work a
lot you have to put a power as he says
that if you put in around 10,000 hours
into that one thing then eventually you
will master that craft I don't know how
close I am to 10,000 hours but every
single time we step on stage we get one
step closer